Thank you very much Sergey That you have
joined me with a new training program
and, for example, also these New classes,
conversations about important things, the new program will be.
I wanted to ask why you think the
state decided to make these changes right now
because it’s such a time, as they say in
Russia, they are canceling
advertisements in transport  including
airplanes in English and how the
news is written and the heart of transport in
connection with the current geopolitical situation
in general, but the school in Russia is 95
percent dependent on the state, the
vast majority of schools in Russia are
state-owned. It is obvious that the
state
remains a big temptation
to use schools as  he has a mouthpiece for propaganda, he
has
thousands of hundreds of thousands of schools all over the
country, it’s
quite tempting to use all these hundreds of
thousands of schools,
which agents of influence, another thing is that
he naturally doesn’t do it very well
because you can conditionally educate
10 propagandists like
Solovyov or  Simonyan, but you can’t
educate 2 million teachers in Russia
for a million teachers in schools, you
can’t educate them so that they
also work there, in general, selflessly and
effectively.
Thank you and
that now, as teachers, I’m thinking about this to everyone,
what’s been said now that
they’re kind of  should teach children how to
operate Kalashnikovs, which is how
these new
versions of the story from a special military
operation
seem to be done. According to the Teachers, or do
you think there are those who seem to not
want to do this in schools about the
typical Russian teacher
of whom 80 90 percent of
school teachers  Russian teachers need to
understand several things from his
anthropological portrait, on the one
hand, these are people who usually have a
mediocre education,
graduated from some regional
pedagogical university,
who went to school, there
is no great desire. Some of them
simply did not find themselves anywhere else;
misfortune, these are poor paid people,
these are state employees  and in many respects does not
depend on the authorities in large cities,
perhaps to a lesser extent, but in
small cities, even more so, there will also be a huge
number of
one school for this entire village. And
in general, this is perhaps the only place of
work,
these people are like such a typical cross-section of
Russian society, dependent
authorities, poor living conditions
poor infrastructure, but at the same time it means
that the problem
is created, we need to add
all the other
friendly people who are just
leading Russia, including. What does this mean
for the fact that now, as it were, children will be
taught all this and, as it were,
Especially for the future Russia, they
will be from  this is kind of a problem when this is
all over in Russia with the fact that
now a whole new generation is being taught
in this kind of ideology, we
all hope that we are all adequately
thinking people, humanists, that when this is
all over Russia will return to the
humanistic path of development,
for example, to proclaim all-  in words,
the priority of human life,
democracy, whatever, the
natural question arises: Where do
these sprouts of
normalization come from, in short, where will
the tree grow that will normalize the Russian as a whole?
it means that the smart, well-read ones who read
Kant there know how
tyranny ends, all that kind of stuff, they will end
and I’ll tell you the
beautiful Russia of the future, it
shows the last year and a half, nothing
like that will happen to me, it seems to me that by their
conciliation, their collaboration,
their readiness to fulfill any order of the
state, the absence of
any
in public
protest against the war by all this In general,
Russian education, whether school or
university, lost the right to,
like the Institute, be some kind of
moral tuning fork to say Well, yes,
our state was so-so But we
had Education And now we
will take these means  there are excellent school directors,
they will become the new
ministers of education, which means we
will begin to teach people differently
sooner or later
income It is clear that nothing like this will happen
since they have shown themselves to be the most
furious collaborators since they have
shown themselves to be people who are ready to do
whatever the state tells them Well
We can expect some positive changes in the future from these people,
but obviously we shouldn’t
understand that, like institutions and schools and
universities in Russia, there are a
large number of
sane people working there who obviously
don’t support all this,
either openly or not publicly
imitate
elitism  It’s possible that
if you
select these people in the right way, you can
arrange a normal civil
illustration. Perhaps on these people
there you are growing the future.
Thank
you for being so interesting
[music]